[Music]
hey you guys time again for the matinee
show this week we're doing we actually
did get to the theater once this week so
we're doing a theater movie at the end
and then the other ones were doing a
shutter exclusive and a Netflix original
yeah so we're covering all the bases
we've been doing that quite a lot the
first one that we're going to talk about
oh man you guys I was so excited this
popped up I was not expecting it popped
up on shutter and this is a documentary
about Tom Savini yeah
now you guys better know who the [ __ ]
tell me yes but I have to tell you this
like I was really excited when I saw
this come out because I am a massive
massive Tom Savini fan when I was a kid
I went to our old like video store which
was like an old shitty movie gallery
with like a porn thing in the back and
they had a document old documentary
about Tom Savini which came out probably
in the mid 80s I want to say it was like
86 87 something like that and I rented
it and I copied it you know i pirate it
on our like little dual deck vcr and i
watched it over and over and over and
over again just because i was so
fascinated by him as a character and
also because I at the time I was kind of
like throwing around the idea of maybe
doing she like Savini Hortman he's a
real man what he's a real man the thing
that's cool about Savini and like I will
say this documentary it was made by a
filmmaker obviously but he's also a
special effects guy named Jason Baker I
believe he got all or most of the
funding for this on Kickstarter I don't
really know how much it costs I will say
from the outset that from a from a
technical standpoint you know as far as
like editing and things like that that
you know the the documentary is a little
clunky or workman like I guess I should
say it's not like you know super
spectacular or anything but if you were
into Tom Savini like as a person because
I feel like the old one that they made
about him that I saw a million times
that focused a lot more on his on the
movies he worked on and like the special
effects work and how he you know how he
accomplished certain effects and things
like that which that which that's cool
and that's interesting but I like that
this documentary didn't
really go the same route as that it does
go a little bit into that but it kind of
goes more into him as a person and like
his background his personal life like
why he made certain career decisions
like why so a lot of the bulk of it is
like interviews with him interviews with
you know people who worked with him at
varying times and so it kind of goes a
lot about his development as a person
and as an artist and stuff like that and
like I said like you said one of the
things that I always liked about Savini
one is he seems to love horror he's very
enthusiastic about and he still is and
however old he is now he's got to be in
his 60s even though it doesn't really
look it we saw him one time yeah we saw
him a couple years ago are you sitting
over at a bus as I see this Tom Savini
and he looked at me like [ __ ] you man
well for a time when he wasn't when he
wasn't really working a lot and he gives
a reason for that in documentary but he
was kind of like solely supporting
himself by going to conventions you know
the circuits of conventions and like you
know paying people had to pay like to
get his autograph and stuff like that
which a lot of people have to do he was
sitting there he was looking [ __ ]
bored he's looking kind of bombed
waiting for people to show up yeah he
was doing a lot of pretty much every
horror convention I've ever been to he's
been at yes on I said I see it Tom
Savini when you probably guess yeah
although I have to say that I mean I met
him once a very long time ago at another
horror convention and he always struck
me like from his interviews like I said
one thing I love about him is like his
enthusiasm like he is and he even like
went into that a little bit on this
documentary about how you know he
doesn't consider it like insulting when
somebody says stop acting like a child
or whatever because he thinks that's
good like to keep kind of a childlike
mentality most people that like
interviewed that were interviewed about
him that had worked with him that
included like George Romero Tony Todd
people like that and they just said that
he was super fun and he's just like you
know he gets [ __ ] done but he's he's
real enthusiasm real childlike and it's
like he's always like ready to kind of
play around and do [ __ ] like it was a
photographer in Vietnam yeah he saw a
lot of cool [ __ ] in Vietnam people
blowing up
of it he did some [ __ ] he tell you tell
some Vietnam stories it wasn't in the
frontline unit but you know he did to do
he did some cool service you know he
didn't just stay at home or anything and
you know he's big into throwing hatchets
and fencing and guns and explosives you
know
nazy the cool [ __ ] yeah I mean like I
see that guy stuff yeah but but in a way
that's like he always came off to me
like just a genuinely good dude he just
seems like a nice man you know that
happens when you have guys that are well
well-rounded and back yeah and he's like
man yeah see he's not a hater yeah he
doesn't yeah he doesn't seem like a mean
person right by any served a lot of
times if a guy doesn't read he's not
real well-rounded he'll get jealous of
something else of something that
somebody else can do so then they start
talking [ __ ] he's talking [ __ ] cuz you
can't do it
well yeah Savini he's kind of guy if he
sees you can do some cool [ __ ] and be
like aw man it was cool I like that yeah
like I said he's very hater he does not
yeah he doesn't seem like better person
at all and like you said that's probably
why and I really liked I was really
fascinated by a lot of the [ __ ] that he
said about his family I mean he grew up
in a very like obviously his parents
were Italian immigrants and he had like
a really large family like I think of
his five brothers there were all much
older so he kind of goes into like his
dad and like all his siblings and like
what they you know what they inspired in
him and like what he admired about them
and stuff and he said that the reason he
became like I said he's essentially a
Renaissance man
yes he's probably best known for you
know his special effects like his gore
you know makeup effects and stuff but he
was also an actor he's a stunt man he's
a stunt coordinator okay dance yeah and
he just says yeah yeah like you said he
does fencing you can ride motorcycles
thinking Jeff motorcycles do what he
ride a bike around oh yeah he was and
did you see uh night rider's yeah from
the 80s yeah they did like they did like
jousting but on me he's good you know
behind the camera in front of the camera
special-effects stunts yeah he does all
the real life you know the man you can
send to Vietnam that's what I mean and
and I like he seems very humble yeah um
I think it's because one because he grew
up for two
it's because he said that he learned how
to do all this stuff because he said my
dad he was like you know a carpenter a
plumber he would say he could do like
everything and he's like so I just
thought well that's what you did you
just learned you got everything so
that's kind of where he got that idea
from so he's just I mean now it's like
you know he he had he opened a makeup
school so he could like help other like
younger artists that wanted to get into
doing makeup and he teaches them his
techniques because he said that when he
was growing up he's like you kind of had
to figure it out for yourself because
it's like yeah you had kind of your big
deal makeup people he's like Dick Smith
was really the only guy that would like
tell you how he did [ __ ]
yeah and like would give them like the
forth his secret formula for like the
realistic looking blood and stuff like
that he's like most of the other makeup
artists working at the time were like
real secretive they were like magicians
yeah he's a magician too but he was a
magician also and a lot of the special
effects that he did in these horror
movies were stuff that he made out of
household implements it's just all do
yourself stuff yeah and again he says
that's probably an imagined from because
of his background because he grew up
poor and he's like you just kind of like
worked with what you had and he's like
so that's what I that's kind of how I
grew up and that's how I learned you can
see it you know a lot of people that you
know kind of come from money their
solution to everything is to buy
something and to hire somebody yeah and
you know he wasn't you know Savini
wasn't like that yeah and he's like
who's gonna ready to stuff we're gonna
put a cabinet here gotta make a sink you
know yeah we got blood and the cool
thing about it is that a lot of his
effects if you see particularly I mean
like I said they go into it a little bit
on this documentary but if you see like
the old documentary again that goes very
into like how he did specific effects
and specific movies it's it's much
simpler than you would think it was like
it looks really good and it looks really
elaborate but when you see how it's done
you're like oh of course you know just
like a magic trick and he's an illusion
yeah and that's what he kind of compared
it to as well that he's like it's like a
magic trick that you're trying to like
fool people into you know showing an
interesting thing about him was that he
seemed to I mean he's been in movies
obviously he was from from Duskull Don
he was an Knight Riders he was in a
bunch of other things and he's done
directing as well he directed the Living
Dead remake in 1990 which actually was
really good with Tony Todd in it yeah um
but it
seemed to me that what he always wanted
he wanted to be an actor and he talked
many times because he's been in movies
he's also like did a lot of work in the
stage like I think it was in North
Carolina I said he kept going back like
every season and like doing all their
live shows and it seemed to me that
that's what he wanted to do even maybe
more than the makeup effects as much as
he loved that and as good as he was at
like all the sculpting and everything
cuz he made like all those creatures
like in Creepshow and stuff like fluffy
and you know the monster in the crate
and whatever so he made all that [ __ ]
but it seemed to me that he wanted to be
an actor first and foremost because I
think at one point he said a little bit
wistfully that he was kind of sad than
ever that he wouldn't be a leading man
because he seemed very self-conscious
about his looks
you know a vallon guy he wasn't and
that's what I mean it's like when you
see pictures of him young he's like all
it took pretty much was that somebody
made a comment about his nose being big
yeah and he kind of got really
self-conscious about it and I think that
kind of and he even said he's like I
think that kind of hindered me later
because I was always thinking about you
know a lot of times in the movies
traditionally they're gonna put like
anglo-american pretty boy in there as a
lead and I think that getting at too
because because he was Italian and he
was very clearly Italian looking well
he'd have made it good you know villain
or oh you know somebody who's you know
you're flying against in another
airplane that type of deal he does
usually play that the sword yeah he kind
of had that dark you know hair and the
mustache yeah yeah you know he
definitely doesn't look like a [ __ ]
yeah you know but he's definitely not
you know I think um I always respected
the guy's work I didn't know that he was
actually a Vietnam vet me being a
extrañar ex-army you knows in the
hundred first Infantry and you know hey
understood him a lot more because when
you actually get deployed to any kind of
war zone you know you you come back out
of that appreciating things a lot more
and you have like a lot of energy and
because you're able to you've seen
really bad [ __ ] or hard stuff
regular stuff you know stuff that you
find back in society is kind of easy
compared to that
it's not as threatening yeah so it's
easier to overcome obstacles you know
you're not hindering yourself so you
know he just cut himself loose let's
make movies let's have fun yes he just
did it and he seemed one thing that I
liked is that he seemed very candid
about I mean that's a little bit how he
got I mean yes he got into like doing
monster makeup from you know seeing lon
chaney and man of thousand faces cuz
that like fascinated him and stuff how
you could like transform yourself into a
completely different person so he was
into that from when he was a kid but he
said that his experiences in Vietnam
because his job was basically after like
the bad [ __ ] happened he had to be the
first one in there to like take pictures
of everything
so he's like so I saw real-life gore
yeah he's like but I had like a little
bit of distance from it because I was
coming at it from behind a camera so I
could pretend that it wasn't real but he
knew what people that you know were
blown up what they look like what that
really look what arms look like just
laying there yeah because he had seen it
yeah and he was also very candid too
about how kind of messed up he was when
he came back from Vietnam you know it
kind of ruined his marriage at the time
even though he had joined the army like
to support his wife and child at the
time and he's like he'd come back he's
like because you just kind of have to
shut off all your emotions like because
you see all these horrible things all
the time so he's like when you come back
home it's very difficult to undo that so
he was like hard to connect with
civilians yeah and he kind of got into
that but this was actually like I said
he was actually surprisingly very candid
like about a lot of things that happened
his personal life at his marriages they
interviewed like some of his grown
daughters who seemed like lovely people
one thing I love is that when they're
kind of showing like what his life is
like now and so you know he's got a new
wife he's been married several times and
he has several children but you know all
of which are grown but he lives with the
the wife the grown daughter and the
daughters son and I love that he
mentioned like when he was talking about
how how he loved his family they said he
mentioned the two cats so I was like ah
that's a that's a point point in your
favor it's like I love when people vet
said their cats as part of the family I
think this one is probably the
definitive documentary on Thompson oh
yeah what do you say about saying oh
yeah I think it's for the best one out
there
like I said it's fun to watch document
yeah and learn a lot of
dating guy and like I said if you're
more into like you know the way he did
specific effects it you know watch the
old one first but then watch this one if
you're more interested like any the man
yeah cuz it kind of goes more into you
know yes it goes into his effects work
but it also goes into like his personal
life and like his stunt work and his
acting and stuff like get a lot of you
get a lot of like testimony from actors
that have worked with him and everything
and stories and [ __ ] yeah I mean
everybody seems to think he's just like
the greatest guy ever which he which is
nice because that is always how he came
across to me and I'd be real like really
bummed out if I found out that he was
like I'll dickwad that he's not fronting
he's not trying to be something that he
is and he's exactly that guy he's a very
like yeah he's a very genuine person he
just comes across like that you know I
don't detect any kind of like what do
you call inadequacies in that man he
doesn't he's like you know I mean he
isn't there's some guys that are out
there you know in the public eye and
they really don't feel good about
themselves because they're kind of like
a sham some of these guys yeah there's
not as much to them as you know they
want you know as meet the eye well now
with Tom Savini yeah there's a lot more
to Tom Savini than meets the eye and he
definitely come he knows as somebody
that one he's very humble too he kind of
knows where he came from and he comes
across as as he knows how lucky he is
that he's and he's like living the dream
and he's like you know whatever happens
that's cool he is self actualized that's
a good way of putting it yeah yeah so
shudder has got this right now it's
about an hour and a half long like I
said from a technical standpoint it's
not like you know the most you know
elegant documentary I've ever seen but
it's um you know if you yeah if you're
into Savini it's really really
fascinating and I really really enjoyed
it and he really enjoyed it too and he
learned a lot about Tom I mean I knew
most of that stuff except it for this
stuff about I know my virgin stuff I
knew he had been in Vietnam I'm special
effects guy but you know you see him as
acting sometimes you know I really
didn't think oh yeah he does tons of
others just like I said he opened that
makeup school and all that other kind of
stuff too so he's kind of like a
Renaissance man and and I'm really
really happy that this documentary got
made because he's an awesome person and
there should be more people like him
really
you
all right so the second one that we're
going to talk about is a Netflix
original now I'm gonna say this right up
off the bat now originally I was going
to review because remember when we did
the show about Canadian crime and we
were talking about that jackhole looka
min yatta oh yeah and remember I said oh
they're doing that Netflix series called
don't [ __ ] with cats yeah okay well that
dropped like yesterday or the day before
and so it was between don't [ __ ] with
cats and Klaus yeah and I'm sitting
there like last night I'm like man it
was like I had a long day and I was just
kind of like I really do not want to
watch something right now we will
probably review it next week though
because I do want to see it I said I'm
more in the mood for like a Christmas
animated movie I was just like I don't
need this [ __ ] after my day so we
watched Klaus instead now I have to say
this is Netflix Netflix is first
original animated film not bad um it is
delightful movie this was actually um
written and directed by Sergio Pablos
now this guy actually worked for Disney
for a very long time and it worked as an
animator on some of their like classic
movies like Aladdin Hunchback of nurture
Dom I don't think the Lion King but some
of the other ones like right around that
time period and he had been wanting to
open his own animation studio which he
did recently I believe it's in Madrid
and what he wanted to do he said that he
was shooting for he's like I wanted to
make a movie that was hand-drawn
animation that is what hand-drawn
animation would look like if all the
animation studios hadn't gone to like
computer animation like in the interim
it looks hand-drawn but it looks baby it
is hand-drawn um so as far as I've you
used computers I'm not sure um how much
computer assistance there was I mean
basically this looks good this is a
hand-drawn film and that was kind of one
of one of the things that he wanted to
do when he opened his animation studio
was make this now this has taken a like
a long time to get made because I guess
they were first like throwing around the
idea in like 2014 2015 he couldn't
really get the funding for it because
they thought it was too risky because
it's hand-drawn animation too expensive
blah blah blah but in 2017 Netflix
decided to
fund it and said yet yes make it we will
give you the money and you know we'll
release it in 2019 yes it's a sad clause
origin story yes it's like an alternate
yeah story for the origin of Santa Claus
yeah it's pretty entertaining but it's
kind of like yeah so it's kind of like
there's this snotty lazy rich kid named
Jesper and I believe it's set in the
19th century like I guess somewhere in
the Arctic Circle they don't know
somewhere you know in the up there and
they don't really specify we're in the
hockey motherland the hockey puck for
Landis Tom calls it here you know I mean
so apparently his dad is like a
Postmaster General and he has like this
big like they've made their fortune like
through the postal service or like you
know he's owns the postal companies or
whatever but his son is such a bomb that
just lays around on his Shaye's launch
like drinking espresso all the time and
ordering servants around so he sends
this lazy son out to this little nowhere
village called smear ins Berg let's go
like out in the middle of nowhere and he
says you have to live there for a year
and you have to like you know send six
thousand letters through the mail and
then you can come back he's like if you
don't do it I'm cutting you out of the
will so this like snotty kid goes to
this town that's full of like he's
[ __ ] it's like a village that's two
extended families that hate each other
it's like the Hatfields and the McCoys
and so like the whole time they're just
constantly trying to like just doing
horrible [ __ ] to each other so he kind
of gets into that they all hate his guts
no one writes letters because they all
hate each other so he's like what am I
gonna do and then finally he meets Klaus
who was this big Santa Claus lookin dude
essentially but he looks were kind of
big and scary he lives like on his own
out in the forest and he makes toys and
so the whole movie is like their
friendship developing him kind of
changing the town for the better like
the kind of the whole theme of the movie
I guess kind of the theme of Christmas
too it's yes it's like a Santa Claus
origin story like an alternate origin
story for Santa Claus but it's also kind
of like you know the central theme of
the movie being you know one act of
kindness Spurs other acts of kindness
and
soon like he just one thing that he
decided to do like changed this whole
you know town for the better changed
everything for the better but it's this
is actually I really really liked this
movie it was like really kind of it's
not really Disney like it's sort of is I
guess because the guy was like a Disney
enemy the animation is beautiful it kind
of reminds me of that much older once
you know that Kris Kringle yeah yeah
stop-motion yeah it kind of reminds me
of that type of that and a little bit of
that look to it yeah and um I just the
character design was really cool like
especially all of the like all of the
horrible villagers like you know it's
like two families like the crumbs and
the Ellen bows and I think mrs. crumb
was the name of the one character with
like that crazy hair or hat or whatever
it was that she had but all of them are
like really strange looking and like
almost kind of look like Addams Family
sort of [ __ ] and there's all this kind
of other kind stuff but the character
design is really cool the story is
really cool it's just like such it I
think this is gonna be one of those ones
that people are just gonna like watch
every year this cuz this just kind of
came out of nowhere it's just really
nice the animation it's just like a
really nice like heartwarming yeah
type of story it has a very classic look
to it oh yeah I liked how it looked the
storytelling was pretty straightforward
the only thing I really didn't like I
liked it overall yeah I don't think that
the only thing that I didn't really like
is I thought that the music selection
because would break out into musicals
was cut very contemporary and it kind of
clashed to me I thought with man with
that victime get it done she felt yeah I
mean I think it would have been better
with a classical score yeah and almost
like a retro musicals assembly yeah then
it came out of the 40's or something
that came out of a 60s maybe you know
like Rudolph the Red Nosed Reindeer you
know them yeah that went along with that
one you know something like that burr
lives or something like that yeah I
would I think I think it may be I think
it should have had like maybe classic
Christmas music in it that's kind of the
only thing I mean it wasn't it wasn't
distracting because I think I mean they
put like a contemporary like pop song in
there just at one point like kind of a
montage type of
yeah and yeah I could have done without
that and you know that I did they did it
during the end credits too but that
wasn't really that big a deal um but
yeah I see what you're saying whether
they get one more totally more classic
motif particularly because this was set
yeah you know a long time ago I guess it
was supposed to be the 19th century but
to me it seemed older you know and I
mean like it seemed like a very old kind
of because you know they're just the way
the villages were it's it's it's a fairy
tale typesetting I would have had [ __ ]
Bing Crosby style [ __ ] kisses Carol's
in it and [ __ ] like that I think yeah
I'm gonna let yeah or even just like not
even vocal stuff yeah just like stuff
instrumental observe you or something
like that just to give it more of a
classic type of feels yeah but that's
really the only really the only thing I
could see that I did I can ding it on I
mean other than that it's like the
characterization is great the voice
acting is great the animation is
gorgeous it's just it's a it's a really
charming story of like how all this how
all the things about Santa like the
flying sleigh the reindeer I'm like
where all that came from you know what I
mean and it's kind of funny like how
they sort of played with a dignity you
know if I was a kid I'll probably have
enjoyed it a lot more I was just
critiquing it mostly as an adult yeah
yeah I mean but if I was you know seven
eight nine I probably wouldn't just
loved it you know and I definitely I
mean I definitely think that this is one
that like the whole family can enjoy you
know what I mean it's not annoying for
adults you know it has like a really
nice heartfelt story like you know the
characters the characters aren't like
zany like over-the-top or annoying or
anything but then there's [ __ ] in there
that will entertain a kid also but you
know it has like a really nice message
like a really nice look to it so I
definitely think that this is going to
become like a Christmas classic along
the lines of like some of them probably
not one of the last you'll see of these
either maybe not and honestly um this
Netflix specifically got this into
theaters for a limited release so they
could put it in for Oscar contention of
Best Animated Feature so we'll see how
that goes because they did get a limited
theatrical release it didn't play here
but um it's been on Netflix for I guess
since the end of November or something
like that and I've been meaning to see
it because I do like Christmas movies
so I mean not stupid lifetime or whole
channel Christmas movies those are
horrible but other guys I like Christmas
horror movies and Christmas cartoons and
then that's about it but yeah definitely
if you need something like heartwarming
and lovely to watch for the Christmas
season you could certainly do worse than
this this is actually a really really
good movie and I really
okay and for our third movie watching
experience this week we actually went to
the theater finally and saw knives out
yeah I've been wanting to see this since
I saw the first [ __ ] trailer however
long ago that was she's been wanting to
see it I thought the trailer looked
pretty good
I had you know I really kind of had to
set my principles aside to go see this
movie because I'm one of the Phantom
Menace types guys that I didn't like
what Rian Johnson did [ __ ] Star Wars
and I was like I mean I will never watch
one of that [ __ ] movies mad I
was that it's calling him Roundhead
Rianne Johnson you know that was
misgendering him calling of her just
doing everything get mad at him you know
I will never watch one of those dudes
movies again he's made a lot of good
movies that saw this movie it was
[ __ ] good movie we made looper he
made brick he made like a lot of good it
was funny it was funny it was it was it
he knew it he knows the genre he hit
that genre real well I remember growing
up in the 70s seeing these all whodunits
back to make them and this is it it's a
modern interpretation of it yeah I'm
still you know there's funny [ __ ]
politics and he kind of makes fun of all
politics like on the right and the left
I guess there's a bunch of jokes about
family it's about a [ __ ] a horrible
family who the patriarch who makes all
the money is found dead upon his sofa
and somebody hires this world-famous
detective to cover him try to figure out
what happened to him and you know of
course the family is all right they want
the inheritance and they're all [ __ ]
parasites you know and it's just it's
it's a [ __ ] nasty family there's I
don't think there's a single good person
in that family kind of yeah no Tommy
Collins character her daughter is
alright but she well she comes across
she seems alright but then at the end
she's just as much of a [ __ ]
you're just so yeah but all of it the
thing about it though is that all the
characters are kind of terrible people
and yet they are super fun to watch know
it's a knot and the only one that's any
good is the little maid and the maid is
played she's a nurse a nurse that's
right yeah the little nurse they treat
her like a maid though they tell her to
go get help and help the nurses that
same actress that played joy out of Anna
Darmouth Ana de Armas that's her name
yeah she plays Julia she's Cuban actress
play joy out of the new Blade Runner
movie she's cute oh she's adorable yeah
and then there's like a all-star cast
got Craig Daniels grace is [ __ ]
amazing
yeah this Don Johnson he [ __ ] did
agree Chris Evans [ __ ] yeah you know
Jamie Lee Curtis yeah it's like this is
this I can't I can't believe they got a
[ __ ] cast of this caliber and like I
said it's I've read some other reviews
of that that are saying it's almost kind
of like a quote-unquote subversion of
the whodunit I don't know if I would
call it that it's almost kind of like
it's like an homage because obviously
Rian Johnson was like a huge fan of like
Agatha Christie murder mysteries and so
this is structured very much like that
but in a way that it's kind of I don't
want to say that it's like winking at
conventions of the genre it sort of is
but it's also a classic example of the
genre if that makes any sense not making
fun of it it's not I mean it's just like
those old if you guys remember like old
ones they did in the 70s you know that a
lot of which were based on Agatha
Christie now they just kind of had fun
with it this is this almost reminds me
of clue you know with the one with um
you know what's it [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my
god my [ __ ] riff raff I don't know
not riff raff you played dr. Franken
first okay don't forget what sock [ __ ]
okay I'll remember later but yeah so
yeah so the one with that movie clue
it's like a slightly less zany version
of that but it in like
best possible way because it's it's
almost kind of like you can tell that
all the characters like all the actors
that are in this or having a [ __ ]
blast like playing these terrible and
yet highly entertaining people Daniel
Craig's got this really [ __ ] cheesy
ass southern accent this he just leans
into that fake as hell yeah but they
like they like maybe Monaghan maybe you
maybe get the foghorn accent yeah it's
funny it's funny I well I kind of feel
like and like I said I think this movie
is doing a lot better than they expected
so Ryan Johnson has said that he's like
he'd like to do another movie with that
character who's his name is Benoit blah
yeah so it's like I like I love that
that's like ridiculous but it's also
like a really good mystery like for real
I you will not guess where the [ __ ] this
is going yeah because lots of twists in
one thing yeah one thing that I think a
lot of people mean when they say it's a
subversion is that you almost find out
what you think is the solution to the
mystery like really soon in the movie
and you're like oh what the [ __ ]
don't ruin it don't no I'm not and then
he's like where the [ __ ] are they gonna
go with that but it's like it's just the
way that it's constructed yeah I mean
the the screenplay the plot is the fist
upon a twist upon a twist it's on a
twist or you or it's a doughnut a hole
the doughnut in a hole and a hole in a
doughnut or maybe you know but it's like
it's just I just love that everyone is
just like playing the [ __ ] out of this
you can tell that everyone had a [ __ ]
blast making this it's like it's really
it's really well plotted like I said you
will not guess where the [ __ ] this is
going because it's just it's twisting
and turning but not in a way that you're
like oh come on there are nothing like
that because it's like [ __ ] that happens
like at the end then you remember like
[ __ ] that happens baguettes like oh he
set that up like you know what I mean so
it's like really really good the way
everything it will interlock it all
interlocks with each other so it's like
when you get to the end and [ __ ] that
seems like it came out of left field it
did it because he set it up at the
beginning yeah and so it's all like
makes sense it's like yeah everybody's
fits in there but it's like I I would be
very surprised I mean we still have
like another week to go and we probably
we're probably gonna see Jumanji or
probably gonna see Star Wars and we're
gonna see stuff like that and that'll
probably be on next week's show but I
would be what we should do for next
week's show too is I already kind of
wrote down some of these I wanted since
it's the end of the year we should
probably write down what our favorite
movies of the year we're that we saw
okay since iris I would be shocked if
this I mean this is definitely in my top
10 definitely I mean I had a [ __ ]
blast with this movie it's like it's
funny as [ __ ] everybody looked like they
had a great time it's and I love
whodunits anyway like that's and I'm and
I'm really happy that like someone is
making one that's kind of like an
old-school one but also a little bit of
an update so I would definitely
definitely recommend this you know I
know people were like [ __ ] crying
about the last Jedi and all other kind
of crap and like I said he's made he's
made other like a lot of other movies
too I mean a lot of other good movie
it's got in MIT I was wrong about Rehan
Johnson he's wrong about it this is the
kind of this is the kind of movie he
needs to make well this is what he's
wanted to it you can tell that this yeah
is something that he's been wanting to
make since he was a kid yeah you know
what I mean and so it just feels like
it's just so cool it's just like this
old just all of the old tropes of like
clue and stuff like that Tim Curry
goddammit yeah yeah why could I not
remember that I remembered it yeah but
it took that long um you know all the
tropes of clues like this big old gloomy
mansion it's like there's a murderer
maybe there's like he's living in a
mansion right at a clue yeah it's like
so they so they are like kind of winking
at the conventions but also it's a
really good example of the convention so
it's not like trying to [ __ ] on it it's
not trying you can tell that you're in
vomit
yeah you can tell that you know that
Ryan Johnson is like really into these
kind of moves and really wanted to make
a good entertaining like old-school type
of whodunit yeah and I definitely think
he succeeded and like I said the cast is
all [ __ ] great
it's a big cast so some you know some of
the actors don't get quite as much
screen time as you might like all-star
cast but I mean everybody when they're
on screen they just knock it out of the
park they're just really funny it's just
like there's just even like some of the
[ __ ] throwaway jokes are
great you know what I mean even the bad
acting is good because they're acting
bad on purpose that's what I mean
they're leaning into like a
ridiculousness and Daniel Craig's
character is like just best where this
comes from you know we were kids our
parents are back in the seventies used
to watch this kind of [ __ ] on television
and even like sometimes you'd have who
done its they'd be making fun of who
done it's like on The Carol Burnett Show
yeah they'd have it and then just you
know I mean it was a trope yeah for them
to like do a scenic whodunit scene
because they're a whole movies like that
yep they were happening on trains and
this just it was part of the genre yeah
and you know [ __ ] sex drugs were part
of the humor they were always making
sexual innuendos and [ __ ] there was
drug and alcohol humor in it and a bunch
of politically uncorrect [ __ ] happening
you know they were they were supposed to
be outrageous out written you know yeah
they were plus we kind of outrageous and
[ __ ] daring and we were talking about
it before because I mean the who done it
is such an is such a you know an old
literary format that you know if people
are saying now oh it's subverting the
genre or whatever it's like genre was
well and the genre has been subverted
because like I said that I get the
Christie books are very very old it's
like they've been parodied they've been
like even back in the [ __ ] 60s in the
70s so like I said this is not like
making fun of it it's like the paint the
parodies were better than the originals
some of them were in a lot of ways
because it gave it gave the comics you
know the chance to do things that were
unacceptable yeah like you talked to a
few slut-shaming characters just [ __ ]
funny [ __ ]
yeah funny [ __ ] yeah but like I said if
you're into clue this this is a bit like
clue but like I said not quite as not
quite as over-the-top I made I love clue
we should probably review that on the
retrospective at some point cuz I'd
[ __ ] love that movie but it's it's
not quite as over-the-top and zany is
that it's a little more I want to say
deadpan cuz that's not exactly right but
it's kind of like the town is more
playful it's yeah it's more of a playful
tone it's not so much like an
over-the-top word cuz then clue like
everyone was kind of like running around
it like oh my god you know what I mean
like that'll but everything there's car
chases in it there's fight scenes every
now and then
bunch of good arguments just [ __ ]
funny jokes funny and yeah it's just
like all of them like playing office
buddies oh so funny
you got carrot lefty characters Shaymin
righty characters and writing characters
shame and lefty characters and they're
all [ __ ] yeah looks like I'm kinda like
I said everyone is terrible except for
the detective except for like the world
protagonist yes like everyone is family
and it's just like funny to watch like
the different ways in which they're
terrible yeah yeah you know when I came
out of the army for a few years I worked
in working wellesley Weston Newton in
Dover which is out there in
Massachusetts and this is set in partly
in Massachusetts I think some of them
were from New York yeah of course but I
think the house was supposed to be in
Massachusetts when I was there you know
I worked with some of the richest
families in the United States and this
this movie nails it that's the word
they're like yeah like I said it's not
in it or not what you think they're like
well like I said that's why I keep
comparing it to clue but it's like I
mean clue they were obviously characters
and it was like a farce and it was
supposed to be like that this is less
farcical yeah because the characters are
over-the-top but not in an unrealistic
I mean you could totally imagine
everything about the mysterious [ __ ]
happening yeah brilla
everything about it was everything about
them was like some kind of stereotype I
personally ran into and there yeah and
those families yeah was totally
believable [ __ ] tons of money none of it
they made themselves [ __ ] crazy
political beliefs on the right and the
left that don't affect any of them at
all
yes [ __ ] just everything is a pair
some of them were kind of parodies of
themselves it's funny yeah
but like I said there's one guy in the
family that makes all the money the rest
of her just parasites on him and yes but
it's basically what was happening in
this yeah and so like I said in that way
like a classic whodunit and just the way
that this does not go in the way that
you would expect at all but not in a bad
way it's like it's the the solution to
the mystery and the solution like the
end is really like really really
satisfying because when you get to the
end you realize that every single thing
was set up yeah so this definitely seems
like one that you need to see like two
times because like I said I think I
missed like
even some of the like throw a throwaway
lines and stuff like that because all
the dialogue and this is so great that
I'm sure I missed some of it I was like
well I you know it was definitely
written to be a donut hole with a donut
inside a hole with a hole inside I just
I died I was laughing when he went to
that job laughing at that Daniel Craig
is so [ __ ] who knew he was so funny
well you don't expect him to be funny
you don't yeah because he's like always
said grizzled and yeah Stern
yeah but he's like actually very very
funny when he wants to be yeah so I
really like that he's kind of like
playing against the usual type and he
totally he totally nailed it yeah I mean
there's just like it adds southern
accent no yeah there's just like just
he's like he was the biggest surprise
for me like him being like really really
funny but everybody everybody and this
is like so good and the girl though oh
yeah yeah yeah she well I loved her in
Blade Runner 2049 she's been his mother
[ __ ] to but it's like everybody
everybody did good job
Don Johnson was refreshing to see he did
a good job he's got to be old as [ __ ]
but he doesn't he doesn't really look
that different looks great you ready he
[ __ ] really he nailed that role he
really did yeah it's just this is just
this is one of the best times I think I
had the theater like the most enjoyable
times this was actually funnier than
some comedies that we saw the whole
audience is you're on it yeah and it's
like there was more people know that I
thought it's been playing for a while so
I didn't think and it was we went to see
it like in the middle of the day middle
the day and it was more than half-full
and it was yeah there was like a [ __ ]
ton of people so I feel like some people
are probably seeing it more than once
like I said because it's one of us
talking about it and referring back to
certain things that happened kind of
like they had seen it a couple of times
yeah so I I definitely feel like this is
one that will reward multiple viewings
because like I said you know the more
times you see it once you know what the
resolution of the mystery is wolf the
resolution the mysteries I guess because
there's a bunch of them but you know
when and then you can go back and like
see like where all the [ __ ] went because
it who definitely does all fit together
and like I said there's probably a lot
of lines in there that I missed because
I was laughing at something else and so
I have to get back there to appreciate
the screenplay yes I think it comes up
yeah I definitely definitely
and and like I said I find it hard to
believe that it wouldn't be one of my
favorite ones of the year because I
definitely had a really good time a good
thing yeah had fun yeah so I'm you know
I'm I was waiting to see this and I was
like really really happy that it was
exceeded my expectations it was actually
much better than
[Music]